tonight's debate couldn't be more timely
just last week the fbi searched former
president donald trump's home in palm
beach florida with warren stating that
he was under investigation for possible
breaches of the espionage act the move
deeply angered trump his supporters and
signaled a major escalation of the
investigations into january 6 and the
final stages of trump's presidency
for some donald trump represents a
threat to democracy and he must be
prosecuted for his actions to send a
message that no one is above the law and
a failure to hold him account they argue
would only embolden him and his
supporters to launch further attacks on
american institutions but others argue
that while trump's behavior may have
been reprehensible the pursuit of a
prosecution would only further damage
the country politicize the justice
system and perhaps boost trump's
narrative of victimhood so who's right
let's go straight to our
initial and our initial and opening
statements
our first speaker is professor david
bligh he's the sterling professor of
american history at yale university and
director of the gilder lehrman center
for the study of slavery resistance and
abolition and he's a pulitzer
prize-winning author of frederick
douglass profit of freedom and a
frequent commentator on donald trump in
publications such as the new york times
and washington post david five minutes
over to you
uh thank you very much connor and thank
you to intelligence scored and thanks to
rich lowery uh in 1861 abraham lincoln
the leader of the original republican
party
during the secession crisis a crisis
like no other in american history
decided uh forthrightly that he and his
party would stand up this secession
they did not acquiesce in secession
lincoln told his
uh supporters he said let there be no
compromise on the question of extending
slavery if there be all our labor is
lost and air long must be done gone
to a southerner he wrote on the
territorial question i am
inflexible
now
um
if lincoln had not stood up to secession
uh the united states would have been two
countries
and a whole different history would have
flowed from it uh speed ahead to 1933
when franklin roosevelt wasn't was
inaugurated
he inherited a massive economic
depression and 25 unemployment his
predecessor
herbert hoover had taken a kind of
laissez-faire approach to the great
depression doing
very little
roosevelt energized government
they passed overnight the banking act
and then a whole series of other
enactments that became known as the new
deal which didn't necessarily save
american capitalism but it certainly
made strides in that direction roosevelt
could have backed off and said you know
this problem is just too vast and
complicated we can't we can't deal with
it
go ahead to uh
1965 uh when lyndon johnson
uh supported after his landsat slide
election the previous year the 1964 and
65
civil rights acts especially the voting
rights act
lyndon johnson an old segregationist
could have said
i understand this white supremacy i was
one of them
uh we can't we can't stop this i'm not
going to get on board for voting rights
because it's going to destroy my
political party the democrats in south
forever
he was not wrong about that
i think of 9 11 when the united states
decided to stand up to terrorist
organizations like al qaeda and went
into afghanistan to find al qaeda what
if we had said you know this is just too
big this is just too
complex of a kind of of a war that we do
not know how to fight
now
it is not
i repeat not illegal to be mendacious
it is not illegal to lie
about an election you lost
the big lie in other words is not
illegal it is not illegal to be ignorant
of history
or ignorant of law in the constitution
which the previous president has
demonstrated
he is
uh it's not
illegal to foment racism with rhetoric
at least and or behavior
it's not even illegal to cozy up to
foreign dictators
such as orban
or
kim jong-un
or vladimir putin what what president
trump did in helsinki
by saying he uh he actually believed
vladimir putin more than his own
intelligence agencies was not
illegal
uh it might have been politically unwise
but not illegal it's not illegal to
spread misinformation about covid from
the white house briefing room
it's not illegal to
maintain over and over that barack obama
wasn't born in the united states
it's not illegal to be an extreme
narcissist
it's not illegal to insult reporters or
to insult
women
by suggestions of sexual abuse
it is not illegal to insult nato members
i could go on there are many kinds of
behavior
that are not illegal they certainly are
impeachable offenses and this president
was impeached twice impeachment
is a political process not
a legal process
but
it is illegal
to uh
engage in obstruction of congress and
its proceedings under title 18 section
1805 of the federal criminal code
it is illegal
uh under the section 3 of the 14th
amendment
to incite an insurrection against the
united states government as long as it
can be proven
it is illegal
to engage in conspiracy to defraud the
united states in title 18 section 371 of
the criminal code
it uh that that criminal code is is in
part about cheating the government out
of money or property but it's
also about using deceit the law says to
obstruct a government function
the to violate the sedition uh
conspiracy act which is title 18 section
2384 of the criminal code
it is illegal
to collaborate with leaders of a mob
interested in overthrowing the us
capital or a procedure of the u.s
congress if that can be proven wire
fraud is very illegal if it can be shown
that a former president used
enormous lies to raise money from his
supporters
it is illegal to
participate in a violation of the
espionage act which the recent
search at mar-a-lago at least suggested
as one of their background laws section
793 of the criminal code makes it makes
it unlawful
to retain
defense related information that could
aid a foreign enemy
in section 15 19 destroying and
concealing documents to obstruct
government proceedings is illegal and in
section 2071
it is unlawful to remove government
records from their appropriate locations
and to willfully
or unlawfully that law says conceal them
now last point
um
we have we do have dysfunctional
institutions but we shouldn't fear that
we have them
um
it is not illegal to be blameworthy of
something
but it is illegal to break laws
openly
willfully
uh we should
we should not fear the virulence of the
right-wing supporters of this former
president and thereby back off from
prosecutions however long and however
difficult they may be
it is fear
that drives the argument it seems to me
that we should not prosecute this former
president we should fear some have
argued the cross-examination that trump
would be put under in a courtroom why
would we fear
cross-examination and lastly
why do we fear continuing
this
melodrama drama
this
uh spotlight that a prosecution would
continue to shine on donald j trump
when he has violated it appears
numerous laws if we fear prosecuting a
former president merely because it
continues the kinds of drama which is
his branding
that he so enjoys then why do we have
law at all
if we truly believe
in rule of law
we will not approach the prosecution of
donald j trump through fear
but through belief that maybe
just maybe some of our institutions
for example the justice system
can be put to the service
of
truth
thank you
david thank you very much i'm philippa
thomas i'm joining connor in hosting
this debate and we're asking members of
the audience to hold your opinions
because of course we have to hear the
other side in this uh
this motion to prosecute trump uh we
want to invite you to hear the case
against and our speaker against the
motion is rich lowry editor-in-chief of
national review and american
conservative news and opinion magazine
rich writes a regular column for
politico he appears regularly on public
affairs programs such as meet the press
is the author also of three books
including the case for nationalism how
it made us powerful united and free rich
you also have five minutes to begin your
case before i come back and the audience
has their turn
thanks so much well thanks for
intelligence squared for hosting these
debates are more important than ever
honored to be here with david blight
there's something called open courses at
yale allows you to listen to entire
lecture series i listened to the
entirety of one davis classes on the
civil war so i'm basically a former
student of david maybe not one of his
favorite former students but kind of
former student so just to situate myself
i'm a conservative republican but i'm
opposed to donald trump so don't take my
word for for it this is i'm reading from
a truth social post by donald trump
himself couple weeks ago refers to rich
lowry who was destroyed and what's
wonderful in influential national view
the pride and joy of the legendary
william f buckley so i'm not a trump guy
but i am opposed to this resolution i
think there are three tests one did
trump clearly and unambiguously violate
the law would this be good for the
country prosecuting him and would it
serve the extremely important political
goal but making sure he doesn't win a
nomination again and is not elected
president of the united states again if
this resolution fails any of those tests
that you go down as it happens it fails
all three so the fact of the matter is
and dude alluded to this uh some once
you get out of the political and moral
realm where clearly what trump did
was abysmal atrocious
literally infamous and get into the
legal realm then you're in a zone where
inherently technicalities and mincing
distinctions
matter it's no longer just rhetoric
these words really count key thing
corrupt intent almost all the the
supposed charges that uh he'd be
prosecuted on
involve corrupt attempt which means
demonstrating that he didn't sincerely
believe that the election was stolen and
i hate to say it i think he is truly
fired with a passionate intensity
and sincerity on this stuff i think if
you put him on a lie detector test he
would pass it without question making
some of these outlandish claims doesn't
speak well of them but just shows that
there's no way you're going to establish
the requisite intent incitements award
that's been bandied about
incitement very specific in u.s law it
means a clear and knowing a call
to
violence right just doesn't mean being
reckless it means a clear and knowing
call for
imminent violence you're not going to
prove that insurrection again you can
throw it around it's good to write in
op-eds but it has a specific meaning and
us statutes rebellion that can't be put
down just by
law enforcement that's not going to
apply here obstructing congress so if
it's a crime
for members of congress to object to the
electors when the other party's
candidate wins the presidential race
then there are many democrats who are
guilty of exactly the same crime
including leaders of the january 6th
committee yes it was insane for trump to
think that mike pence could unilaterally
change the the account of the electors
on january 6 but we don't prosecute
people for insane legal theories and
then just to underline this point the
technicalities matter once you're in
you're in the legal realm once you're in
the courtroom we all know the call that
trump had in georgia with the secretary
of state you got to find me 11 000 votes
if you actually read the transcript of
that call which is what will happen in a
court of law trump makes it clear he
thinks there's a pool of 400 000
fraudulent votes so he's not just saying
go manufacture eleven thousand he's
saying go find these votes that i know
are fraudulent he has two or three
lawyers on the call with him people
usually don't commission felonies with
in the company of their lawyers and the
lawyers say look we've done fine grain
analysis we believe there are tens of
thousands fraudulent votes and the
takeaway at the end of the call
is can we have a meeting with you
secretary of state's office and you can
explain how we we're wrong i'm sorry no
one is going to jail for that call no
one is going to jail for that call so
the legalities really matter and they're
just they're just not here now second
test is it good for the country
no uh whatever we might like if you saw
the reaction to the fbi search and you
thought that was over the top and
hysterical just wait just wait to to
he's prosecuted you think this country
is divided now just wait until you try
to to uh prosecute him there's a reason
we honor gerald four for pardoning
richard nixon it's because he got the
country out of the box now you have
people firmly saying we need to get in
to this box and we'll invite retaliation
you prosecute trump republicans win the
presidency in 2024 i guarantee you joe
biden will be prosecuted for something
by the republican-led justice department
maybe having to do with the sleazy
dealings of his son hunter biden and
then finally the name of the game here
is make sure donald trump is not
president again
the fbi search was the best day
politically he's had in a very long time
if you prosecute him it'll even be
better for him so in summary
the chant locker up when republicans
were saying that about hillary clinton
was dumb and unworthy the same is true
of lock him up this resolution must and
should fail
rich thank you very much
powerful stuff from both of you and i
think this is a good point in which to
reveal the results of the poll to see
who has the greatest challenge here and
we can say that
coming into this debate
for the idea that donald j trump should
be prosecuted 81 percent
rich the challenge is
is the largest
things things are always darkest before
they go completely black
five percent say no
but 14 are undecided i find that uh
particularly interesting uh now we are
going to bring in audience questions uh
and i'm just going to remind you that uh
connor's told you about how to do that
to click on the ask question tab tell us
your name if you want your name to be
read out as part of the question
but before we start audience questions
uh first a short apology from me
yes we do know how to video conference
but mia culpa my internet
fell off the air the minute we started
that hasn't happened to me before in
years of actually presenting television
from my living room during pandemic so
my apologies to the intelligence squared
audience that was me let's hope it
doesn't happen again but um connor is
safely with you to shepherd you through
can i pick up um
just a thought for for david and and for
rich here
because there doesn't seem to be a real
debate between you about the morality of
the actions of donald j trump but we
heard from rich there a very strong case
that donald trump believes he won donald
trump believes there were pools of extra
voters that
weren't counted he believes he was
swindled out of his second term
david
who are we
to say we can judge his psyche that he's
making it up
we're not judging his psyche
and he's not being put on trial if he's
put on trial
for his beliefs
it is the
federal code against
conspiring to defraud the united states
where the georgia phone call which was
brought up
would be prosecuted
and in that law it says using deceit
to
thwart a government function
can anybody listen to that call to the
secretary of state of georgia
and say
trump was not making something up does
it matter whether he believed it his
actions
in all of these cases his actions are
what should be prosecuted not his
beliefs
we would be here forever trying to
prosecute donald trump for
immoral acts
and in fact
immorality isn't necessarily illegal is
it but actions
violating federal law
yes they are and and
to what extent are we going to continue
to argue that this man is so
disassociated with truth
that he is incapable of knowing his own
actions
yeah i'm sorry just as a matter of law
and i know this isn't satisfying but as
a matter of law
any number of these supposed charges do
require corrupt intent and david even
just what you said deceit
that deceit means
a willful effort to mislead you know
it's wrong you know you're lying and you
you do it anyway and i'm just saying as
a matter of law look i don't think it's
it's worse that he believes this stuff
as a moral matter as a political matter
it's worse it makes it more important
that he should go away and to be
defeated politically but legally it's
not just the act it is the intent and if
and again david i think has conceded the
point by the use of that word deceit as
a very specific meaning in the law and
again i think we both agree about this
we're not talking about morality we're
talking about the law and the law is
often unsatisfying if you are just
seeking a moral or political outcome
which i think i understand the impulse
which i think a lot of people are doing
here but it's misapplied in the legal
realm it will backfire you'll end up
losing the case you'll end up losing the
case and giving him a bigger victory
which would be just perverse so don't go
down the route in the first place but
rich can i just pick up on on this point
because there is an argument that
uh
the case will be lost he'll gain support
he'll emerge from this stronger but
isn't the the point of principle
that doesn't make it
right to leave him be if there are
clearly indictable offences here if if
there are clearly indictable offenses
which there aren't so i have a
multi-layered argument just on on the
legalities i don't think david has made
a case um i don't think the case is is
there and if you're gonna be you can't
be the least bit adventurous or novel in
a case that this that is this
consequential that that's just a very
bad thing if he shoots someone on fifth
avenue you know if the midtown
prosecutor is investigating shootings in
midtown manhattan and it arises if
donald trump shot someone on fifth
avenue there's no doubt right
and we don't need to know why he did it
even he shot him okay prosecute him but
this is all extremely uh murky and a lot
of it involved i'm sorry to say you know
a lot of it involves intent
but rich you're saying that donald
trump's intent is only to be judged by
some small group of lawyers who were
sitting with him when he made that call
to the secretary of state that he is
utterly incapable of knowing his own
intent i'd like to see some prosecutors
with him on the stand take him to task
about just what he knows and doesn't
know
no i i that's not what it is
his psyche is not on trial his actions
are
well again david intent matters so if
you say a psyche is not on trial you're
saying intent doesn't matter as a matter
of black and white law i remember these
statutes the intent does matter and i'm
not saying it's it's the judgment of a
couple lawyers i'm saying everyone you
know some of the most compelling
testimony january uh six committee was
his insider saying mr president is not
there there's no there's no fraud you
know bill barr mr president's bs and
they asked don't borrow what did the
president say he didn't accept it he
argued back he pushed back in every
single instance so again the legal
realm's not satisfying in these respects
i was i would think a number of people
supporting this resolution they want a
certain moral and political outcome
impeachment didn't work um they're going
to this and he committed impeachable
offenses up the wazoo okay but you can't
uh prosecute someone for an impeachable
offense of this nature it was a
political offense it was a moral offense
against our system once again again into
the legal realm it's just a whole
different zone and i'm afraid david
hasn't made the case on that but rich by
your logic if he fired a gun on fifth
avenue and killed somebody and then he
went in and said i don't believe i did
it
well i don't believe there's a dead body
there fingerprints on the gun and
there's a bullet that can be traced to
the gun that see there there's not murky
it's it's a clear violation of the law
and if you got him on that i'm going to
uh be open to maybe there something like
that emerges but it hasn't yet i think
it says quite a lot doesn't it that
rich you're saying there would pretty
much have to be a dead body on the
streets
with donald j trump's fingerprints on
him
it would have to be something clear yeah
a clear violation of the law you know a
meeting with the oath keepers in in the
white house the week before
you guys are storming the capitol i know
about the capitol here's a map here's
where you guys go all right
um a speech on january on the morning of
january 6 attack the capital that's what
incitement is the united states has a
first amendment and incitement is not
protected but it's narrowly drawn not to
intrude on free speech rights so you got
to say go attack the capital
that's incitement i'd be in favor of
indicting him in a minute on that but
that's not what he said in fact he
covered himself by saying you know be
peaceful court a law now you might say
be peaceful roll your eyes court a law
and that's the realm you want in you
want to get out of the moral political
realm you want in the legal realm court
of law that's gonna matter
there are questions coming in and
actually i think what i'd like to do is
encourage those who are listening
perhaps especially those of the 14 who
don't know what they think yet about
whether donald trump should be
prosecuted uh encouraging you to to
bring in your questions i'm going to
start bringing in a few because i think
they'll add to the themes that we can
kind of back back and forth and kind of
explore a little more um
actually the first question that came in
says does rich believe trump has broken
any laws since the start of his
successful presidential campaign
do i believe he's broken any laws um
no
i
i um
this this is the problem is
so often in u.s politics and this has
been true since watergate we want to say
because someone did something wrong we
disagree with or
represented a threat to the
constitutional system it must be a
violation of the law now i think the
repurposing of the
military funding to go to build the
border wall was an abuse
was illegal
um but it wasn't you know it's not a
crime the way we're talking about this
barack obama did the same thing when he
rewrote immigration law
union unilaterally to
regularize the status of a bunch of
illegal immigrants that also was illegal
but you wouldn't prosecute barack obama
for it you wouldn't prosecute trump for
that it's impeachable it's it's
technically impeachable you want a
higher level i think a political offense
to impeach
but again just because something's bad
and i thought david is very powerful on
this in his opening remarks it doesn't
make it illegal and if you get into the
legal realm it's not it's not healthy
and good for a country we should we
should argue our politics out in the
political realm to the extent it gets
into the legal realm it's we've already
seen some of this it's going to hollow
out our our legal institutions
especially if you're stretching to get
someone because you consider them
especially noxus that creates the
predicate for someone else stretching
and you're not going to like it when
they stretch to get your side
don't do it that's that's my um that's
my
make the political case make the moral
case don't do this
so rich you would argue that all of the
efforts trump made and his people around
him made to get mike pence
as vice president to stand up and stop
the count in the congress all of those
efforts are just free speech
yes i think they're wrong they're
grossly i'm not asking whether they're
wrong they can agree that they're wrong
but a president of the united states is
organizing his power to get his vice
president to stop the count to stop a
legitimate congressional function
is just his free speech and not
well as a legal matter it's not illegal
it's grossly wrong and impeachable and
in fact he was impeached for it but
would you just i know you wouldn't
prosecute him but jamie raskin is he
guilty of a crime the democratic
congressman from maryland because he
objected to uh electors when you know
george w bush was elected or or trump
was elected is that that's a crime or is
it actually part of the process where
you have this push and pull um on
over electors and debate about it and if
someone's if someone's grossly violates
the spirit of the system
you impeach them can i just at this
point bring in something that could
change the facts
that could change the shape of this
debate uh over the coming days or weeks
and i'm thinking about the mar-a-lago
raid um david your thoughts first on
whether you believe donald trump could
be prosecuted or jailed for espionage
well it actually doesn't matter what i
believe if indeed
under the three laws cited in the
warrant we don't have the affidavit yet
to know the detailed argument for it
but if in any one of those three laws
cited espionage act then section 15 19
then section 27 1 of the federal code
if indeed trump took
top secret and beyond top secret
documents to mar-a-lago
all on his own
uh
having
no right to do it
uh are you hearing me okay yeah you're
fine yeah okay okay okay um
uh and and
and the justice department chooses to go
to court in other words they indict him
and chooses to go to court and they can
demonstrate that yes he ordered people
to put those in boxes and get him out of
here and get him on the airplane in some
chaotic situation he violated the law so
maybe that ultimately is where the case
will be made but i do think the justice
department has a hell of a lot to work
with from the january 6 committee
already but this approach is th this is
a deeply illiberal approach if you
forgive me
usually what we do we look for
violations of the law and then we see
someone violates them and then we go
after that person you don't focus on a
particular person say maybe i'll get
them on this i get him in this and get
him on that i don't get him in that i
can really stretch and maybe get him on
this that's not the way it's supposed to
work and you never know about me
you've had legal jurors on both sides
saying this is a really bad way to go
about it and the problem you're going to
have
we need to know the facts i mean the
facts are facts are always important
what was going on in mar-a-lago but you
can't say
james comey as i'm not saying you say
this david maybe you believe hillary
clinton should have been prosecuted you
can't say james comey was a great act of
statesmanship to choose not to prosecute
hillary clinton for her violations of
the handling of classified material and
then say we got to get trump those
things don't add up and if you try to do
it you will cause this conflagration
because people will not accept the
legitimacy of it they'll think it's
unfair and selective and again that's
getting your politics into the the legal
realm and destroying your legal system
tom
i think this is relevant at this point
david tom asks how do or perhaps how
could trump voters get on board with
prosecution if you're making the case
for prosecution and you're sitting in a
room full of loyal trump voters david
what do you say to them above all
well
i will try to make them
talk you might feel like you're in the
lion's den a little uncomfortable
argument
i think rich is even going to have
trouble with those people especially
they're going to hate him more than me
but i'm going to try to get them to talk
to me about facts
i'm going to try to get them to talk to
me
about questions of truth
and then i'm going to try to get them to
talk to me about
complicity by the president of the
united states in fomenting that mob that
attacked the u.s capitol and then if
it's about mar-a-lago i will ask them to
withhold judgment
until the justice department however
long it takes them
decides
whether to indict to charge or not and
if they do
i would simply ask them to read these
laws
to read the actual content of the
federal code and actually perhaps
millions of americans are reading the
federal code for the first time this is
a good a good historical legal education
i would ask them to simply try
to have an open mind that this is not
just an attempt to get trump it is so
so we didn't even know about the raid in
mar-a-lago until last week
so david let's say one of one of those
uh trump voters says well professor
blight you make a make a lot of sense i
love your work frederick douglass
biography is awesome which it is i'm not
just making that up as a hypothetical
um why didn't you want to indict hillary
would you have indicted hillary over her
violations of the handling of classified
material
because that's the first thing i'll ask
you
in retrospect uh no
but i'd have to go back and look at
those facts again that happened
it was a technical violation of the law
there's no doubt she violated the law so
the new standard is if any of our
politicians violate the law we're
nailing them to the wall no matter what
no matter what the political effect no
matter how it drives people crazy then
you you have to favor indicting her too
and then we're already in this
tongue okay but rich rich i'm gonna ask
you here it was the same thing i would
ask those trump voters in a room
are there not qualitative judgments we
must make qualitative judgments are
always made under the law judges make
them every day supreme court supreme
court justice courts of appeal justices
make them every day the violation
hillary clinton committed of getting a
second server
for documents uh that's that's one kind
of uh violation and if it was a
violation
maybe just maybe
there should have been some
uh answering for that before law
but qualitatively
gathering up absolute top secret
documents for whatever his motives were
and we don't know that yet whatever
purposes he may have had whatever sheer
sloppiness he had with with major
documents is qualitatively
of a different level of violation of law
than what we can claim
hillary clinton set up a server system
explicitly to have an end run around the
state department's protection of
classified documents and again you're
slipping into and how you characterize
trump
at the end there you're saying it's
sloppiness well if you're you're the
making the qualitative judgments
sloppiness is different than you know
having a blueprint of a hyper sonic
missile to sell to the russians right
there are many in the audience who are
very engaged with this and i just want
to bring in a couple of points uh one
that may be relevant at this point from
lois mcmillan who's in oregon uh saying
look aren't we a nation of laws
shouldn't every president be above the
law perhaps turning back your point on
you there rich she asks you uh how can
your criteria that we don't apply the
law because it may further divide the
country or re-elect trump uh how can you
stand by that she says isn't every
president above the law including yeah
now my first criteria is he has to have
violated the law in some sort of clear
and ambiguous way and the the first of
my three-part test
is that very question and i think i've
quite persuasively argued no he he
hasn't uh it's all it's all speculative
it has to do with intent which we sort
of agree david doesn't think you have to
improve intent but you do and i think
the intentions are very difficult and
then i didn't know
you did earlier but if you think we have
to prove his intent then as we go to my
point that it
you you characterize it as having to
read a psyche get get to his and
that's when i'd like to see prosecutors
take on his intent in a courtroom but
but you don't just like do it for fun
and you don't do it for show and you
don't do it because oh we're going to
stick it to this guy
uh no
if you don't think you can why do you do
it is another question from susan in the
audience she says david don't you think
it's just that democrats are scared of
losing 2024 that's why they want him to
go to jail so he can't run isn't that
part of the motivation
no it isn't at all let him run
no
what what this is really no sure there
are democrats who who want revenge
against donald trump and revenge against
trumpism of course there are but this at
this point historically is a matter of
can
a president while in office
commit crimes
that he never has to answer for
and after he's out of office to continue
to peddle
the message of his crimes uh without any
impunity forever just because we fear
that his supporters might become violent
what if what if that's what lincoln had
done in 1861 and just said oh you know
these people are going to get really
violent we better back off or lbj had
said oh my god you know white
supremacist and south are going to get
really violent now and they did i think
we have another audience question which
which does tails onto what you're saying
before i just let rich come in which the
questioner says what does rich believe
the message that not prosecuting trump
sends what is the message that is sent
to the january 6th attackers
that we're a nation of laws and if you
violate the law we will prosecute you
the january 6 rioters the vanguard of
those people
violated any number of laws
and they have been prosecuted up
and down appropriately
so and if donald trump actually incited
them as a legal matter again
incitement's a legal term it's one thing
to write it or say it in an op-ed or on
cable tv but in our legal system it
means something very specific a really
high threshold he didn't trump didn't
meet that threshold doesn't mean that he
wasn't reckless doesn't mean that it was
horribly wrong it was it's just not
illegal again i'm just repeating myself
it's not satisfying but that's that's
the way that the legal system works and
you don't prosecute someone because you
don't like him getting away with saying
lies the way to stop him uh or to make
him pay the ultimate price for for
saying lies isn't to like prosecute him
and boost him up and go through a
two-year drama that's going to lead to
nothing is to defeat him politically it
is to defeat him politically and um if
you don't have a legal case and then
you're relying on this oh we'll make him
go away and pay a price for for lies the
way to make him pay a price is to have
him go away and that process was was
happening slowly but surely uh he he was
losing his grip now thanks to the fbi
he's he's been boosted up again that's
uh
[Music]
may i make one simple point i am not
arguing that donald trump should just be
prosecuted because a whole lot of people
don't like him and i am not arguing that
he has indeed broken these laws i'm not
a lawyer and i do not know i don't work
for the justice department i am simply
saying that rich is essentially making
the argument that there's so much fear
in our political culture about what will
come of this that we should therefore
not do it i'm saying we should not act
yes or no on this problem just out of
fear but david
all right
just one just one very very one thing
okay if you don't if you're sorry if you
don't know he broke laws you should not
be arguing in favor of this resolution
can i come it's not for me to say that
he broke laws i'm not the president why
are you arguing in favor of the
resolution
i'm saying that if indeed the justice
department makes a case based on this
array of laws that they have already
said they
may have violations and of course he
should be prosecuted
we can feel that that's not the
resolution that's not your that's not
the resolution you're not now you're not
defending the resolution and we can feel
the heat and i'm going to ask you both
to listen to this question from cara
because
well i want you to i want to see whether
you take the question seriously cara
asked both speakers
do you worry the trump prosecution could
become a new civil war
david
uh
i think in a sense we already have it
it's it's not a civil war in any sense
that americans remember
the real civil war
uh we have we have civil conflict
we have
egregious terrible polarization in our
political culture
we have uh division
that does not lend itself to any kind of
comity or compromise we already have the
conflict what i'm trying to say here is
i don't believe this is risking civil
war it is risking
further civil conflict but the stakes in
this
are the question of whether we have rule
of law
and whether we have respect for the very
institutions that riches argued are not
functioning very well it's possible just
possible here
that our justice system could prove that
it is working and it may even prove that
rich by deciding uh garland and the
doj may decide not to prosecute which
alone would be that would be wise
well i'm with you
but let's let the justice department
decide that but the thing is
what you're arguing about they shouldn't
even be consistent because there's not a
violation there's not a we would know
a layman a layman would be able to
examine the evidence and look at the
statute and say yes you can't do that
because you don't work for the justice
department of course i don't but i do
this for a living i i i read and analyze
just the way you do just in a different
room
it should be clear
violation rich larry on the use of that
phrase civil war
whether you think it's relevant
what do you think about it even being
brought into this debate
oh i think it's it's hysterical at this
point um look if if a
an ambiguous um adventurous unwarranted
prosecution of donald trump and i think
that's what we'd be looking at now
garland is under massive political
pressure from democrats to do this and i
fury he's buckling
would
bring us closer to some sort of breaking
point but the civil war
no you know and i just think civil war
analogy is that january 6 was terrible
but if fort sumter had involved you know
people breaking into
breaking into the fort and parading
around for a while and then getting
arrested and thrown in jail we wouldn't
had a civil war uh there was no
breakaway republic of stop the steel
we're far away from that point but i do
think our institutions are under stress
and it's not the best stress desk for
the justice department conor encountered
what david says will not be a
highly contentious radioactive
prosecution on dubious grounds that's
not
that's not the test you want for the
integrity of the justice department and
strength as an institution i just want
to listen
to something that you said rich you said
it could bring us to some sort of
breaking point
i just think it's further further down
the road of division further down the
road of no one trusting uh one another
further down the road you know it wasn't
a rhetorical point i made at the
beginning i think it's literally true if
republican wins in 2024 and there's some
significant at least 50 maybe higher
percent chance
and and um trump is prosecuted on those
dubious grounds it will happen to joe
biden and that's just it's something we
haven't done as a country everyone's
engaged in forbearance and statesmanship
and that's called for here don't do this
merrick garland i know you're feeling
the pressure
don't do it
but rich you just said you quote fear
that merrick garland is feeling this
pressure and buckling your word buckling
yeah how do you know that just because
he authorized a search of mar-a-lago is
it not possible rich
that merrick garland was delivered by
his aides this list of documents high
top secret possibly nuclear information
and he's told these have been in in
mar-a-lago for a year and a half we we
were told we got all of it out in june
now we learned we didn't get auto all of
it out by any means we've been asking
and asking and asking
uh mr attorney general you're gonna have
to go in with a warrant and take them
does that mean he's under democratic
party pressure or he's responding
to his legal responsibility
yeah so again we don't know the fact
specifically about mar-a-lago i'm
willing i changed my mind based on
on uh new facts but i said fear
knowingly like advisedly right i don't
know he's buckling to pressure but
certainly all the indications the
presser is massive
on him up and down from the democratic
party from um
large sectors of the press and my read
again it's speculative because we don't
know anything about mar-a-lago in detail
is that might have been related to
january 6 subsection
c
of the appendix of the warrant says you
can take anything any any record created
by president trump the four years of his
presidency which some some people
suggest well that's really wide-ranging
and maybe that means you're trying to to
gather more evidence related to january
6. certainly timing is interesting
because it coincides with these january
6 related uh searches of a congressman
and a couple of lawyers so that would
suggest this related january 6. so i i
think if he indicts trump on something
january 6 related unless there's some
smoking gun that we're not aware of
it'll be buckling to pressure it will be
a dubious prosecution it will very
likely fail and then also have
disastrous political effects for the
country and just picking up on that rich
and uh a question that's come in uh
for you what is the stronger argument
against prosecuting trump that it'll be
hard to convict him or that it will
further polarize u.s politics you've
spoken to both these yeah the strongest
is
the legal
the legal case the standard is you got
to believe you're going to
convict and sustain the conviction now i
you can probably convict him of anything
uh in front of a dc jury this at this
point but are you gonna sustain it under
appeal are you gonna stain it as it goes
up the system
no very very unlikely again not not
based on anything that anyone knows at
the moment
i am just about to give you both two
minutes to sum up i am just going to
bring in a question before that which
has popped in which is kind of
intriguing david is it possible to do a
plea bargain with trump what would you
think about that
well i don't know what form it would
take what would it mean that he uh
what that he releases even more
documents what would the plea bargain be
you don't have to go to jail sir
if you tell the truth
i mean uh this man has such a troubled
relationship with truth i don't think uh
that's gonna get us anywhere uh
plea bargain meant that you wouldn't run
for president again i suppose
all of this is an unprecedented ground
as rich well knows uh the idea that the
justice department would make a plea
bargain with a former president
and the deal would be you don't run
again because you're you're a danger to
the country or something uh no i i don't
i don't think and that would uh be worse
than a gerald ford pardon in terms of
leaving ambiguity in our legal structure
for years and years to come what's
ultimate well i'll say yes may i may i
ask you to pause because i'm i'm going
to in just a few minutes give our
audience the chance to vote again and
tell them how they voted before that i
would like to offer you both uh a
two-minute closing statement i've
actually got a stopwatch here because
i've gone a bit long so
rich lowry may i invite you first to
make uh your statement as to why there
should not be a prosecution of donald
trump yeah so before i do that i just
want to thank you i want to thank the
audience members i want to thank david
for his uh passionate sincerity on this
and on so much else i've listened to you
over the years david you you are you you
believe in what you consider truth and
justice and i always
respect that so it's been an honor being
here with you this afternoon so i would
just
sum up by saying no one's above the law
and no one's beneath the law so you
don't want to go out of your way
because you consider him a noxious
figure to stretch to find some dubious
legal theory or grounds to
prosecute him that would be wrong that
would be a violation of the spirit of
what's supposed to be a nation of laws
and as i've made clear you know i
understand the sentiment of wanting to
make him pay a price for what he did
it's deeply unsatisfying he got
impeached he didn't get convicted he's a
leading candidate for president again
that's uh that no one should be happy
with with that but this this is the
legal system's not the way to do it
there's no scenario there's no scenario
where he's going away to federal
penitentiary for five to ten years never
to be heard from again there's no
scenario where he's you know he's going
to be banned from running for president
because what a statue says all those
requirements are in in the constitution
so you want to stop him from having the
sweetest revenge which is being behind
the resolute desk again
smiling two thumbs up that's what you
want to avoid and a prosecution a
dubious prosecution is not the way to do
it trust me i live and breathe
republican politics it will backfire
miserably please don't do it please vote
against this resolution
rich lowry thank you i'm going to give
the same time which was one and a half
minutes to david blight
well thank you rich and i greatly
respect the positions you've taken on
donald trump in recent years i do
uh first of all there's no dubious
theory of law in those three statutes
that the justice department named in
that warrant at mar-a-lago that's not a
dubious theory of law he either took
those documents illegally or he did not
i believe rich lowry has made his case
here essentially on the argument of fear
we should fear ever having donald trump
as president again we should fear the
violence that may come from a legitimate
prosecution if the doj chooses to
prosecute we should fear a
cross-examination in court which seems
extremely strange to me we should fear
that we can't prove intent
i don't think we need to be thinking
about this in terms of fear of course
there could be violence out of this
there already has been but if we just
back away
and say because donald trump is so
dangerous socially
and politically
we should never prosecute him i think
rich lowry is most interested in finally
getting donald trump
out of the way of poisoning his
political party which he has done
and there are is more than one way to
get donald trump out of our politics a
prosecution is not necessarily the best
way i agree with you and i'm surprised
trump hasn't actually announced his
candidacy already but fear should not be
the basis on which we apply the law
david thank you rich thank you both for
being so succinct we're going to put up
our final vote uh for you the audience
to say whether you believe there should
be a prosecution of donald trump uh or
not
so we're going to ask you what you think
and a reminder that at the opening the
votes were 81 in favor of prosecution 5
against an undecided 14
now i can't see here whether the votes
have come up so i am on tenterhooks
as to whether we are being given a vote
or not
oh the world's waiting the world is
waiting if not i'm going to remind you
that you can tell us whether your mind
has been changed uh on social media
twitter the hashtag is iq2
and i am oh we're just coming up with
the vote uh oh really on tenterhooks
just a few seconds to go and
i'm going to ask you to vote then we'll
get you the results as soon as possible
and i'm going to thank both of you for
your clarity and depth of thinking and
your good humor given that this is such
an emotive such a difficult debate and
the political state of the nation hinges
perhaps upon what we've been talking
about
but we know from the questions that came
in and i'm sorry i wasn't able to get to
all of them
that there are very strong feelings
about criminality morality sanity donald
trump's future
and there we go a final vote
72 percent
think donald trump should be prosecuted
26 disagree now
it says twelve percent undecided i'm
trying to do the maths here seventy-two
percent agree
26 disagrees so you have rich won over
some for your cause how about that
how about that thank you both very much
thank you to the audience thank you for
your patience too and your patience with
me the presenter for failing to appear
at the top of the show uh it has been
fascinating and i'd also like to thank
intelligence squared for bringing us
together and bringing the audience into
this live hour there's going to be a lot
more said about this in the weeks to
come thank you